oh j'ai hâte que ce soit rendue à 40 le
moment tant attendu est enfin arrivé
j'ai très hâte de me faire vacciner j'ai
très hâte que ma soeur et mon copain ils
seraient sanctionnés aussi après des
mois d'attentes la vaccination sera
progressivement ouvertes au grand public
dès cette semaine
maintenant il n'y a plus aucun doute
revoir réaliser notre objectif du 24
juin à compter de demain les 50-59 ans
pourront prendre rendez-vous en ligne
les 45 49 le pourrons le 3 mai les 40-44
le 5 mai et ainsi de suite jusqu'au 18
24 le 14 mai le ciel commence à se
dégager et on commence à voir vraiment
des rayons de soleil au cours des cinq
prochaines semaines plus de deux
millions et demi de doses sont attendues
essentiellement en provenance de
feuillus et de moderna pour injecter
tout ses 12000 vaccinateurs de plus ont
été formés en une semaine et une dizaine
d'entreprises seront mis à contribution
dès lundi on verra aussi les horaires
des centres de vaccination avec des
clientèles plus plus jeune donc son seul
marché du travail nous on veut s'assurer
avec toutes les sauces et les yeux
d'avoir des d'avoir sur des heures
allongé mais surtout avoir
d'accessibilité des fins de semaine un
projet pilote de vaccination à l'auto
sera aussi mise en place dans la grande
région de montréal
comme c'est déjà le cas ailleurs des
belles formules qui vont faire que ça va
être très très pratique pour certaines
familles de dire on est dans notre bulle
on n'est qu'à % voire un auto pour se
vacciner
on espère vacciner 75 % de la population
dans tous les groupes d'âge mais la
santé publique ne s'avance pas sur les
assouplissements qui pourrait venir
une fois l'objectif atteint faut pas
penser à trouver un chiffre magique ça
vaut véritablement être sur la base de
notre épidémiologie est ce ça va
toujours venir documenté et nous faire
ajuster notre stratégie les nouvelles
sont encourageantes sur le front de la
vaccination mais la situation demeure
fragile
à preuve une vaste portion du
bas-saint-laurent passera sous le coup
de mesures spéciales d'urgence des
samedis ici hugo lavallée radio canada
québec